[Musique]
David guinotta bonjour vous êtes
écrivain aussi en sciences politiques et
vous publiez j'ai exécuté un chien de
l'enfer c'est une enquête sur la mort de
Samuel Paty que vous sous-titré
d'ailleurs un rapport sur l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty peut-être un mot avant de
commencer pourquoi ce terme de rapport
vous savez le terme officiel le titre
officiel du rapport de l'Inspection
générale c'est rapport sur les
événements
survenus à Conflans au collège du bois
d'aulne pour être exactement pour être
précis et le nom de Samuel patine
apparaît pas moi j'ai raconté l'histoire
du point de vue de Samuel Paty d'où le
titre rapport sur l'assassinat de Samuel
Tati donc vous avez un rapport qui prend
le point de vue de l'administration et
mon souci c'était de prendre le point de
vue de l'individu singulier qui a vécu
cette épreuve alors on va on va parler
évidemment du livre peut-être un mot
quand même des commémorations qui ont eu
lieu un an de
[Musique]
l'ambiguïté fondamentale
à l'occasion de ce type de cérémonie on
peut rendre hommage pour tourner la page
et pour oublier alors hommage pour ne
pas trop parler des détails de ce qui
lui est arrivé exactement ou bien on
rend hommage pour essayer de comprendre
ce qui lui est arrivé exactement afin
que ça ne se reproduise pas et qu'un
autre professeur ne passe pas par la
même épreuve et je pense que vous avez
là deux
tentations et qui sont d'autant plus
fortes la volonté de tourner la page et
d'autant plus forte que le traumatisme
était très important alors venons à
votre livre
ça arrive très précis le mot rapport
n'est pas innocent dans ce livre
ce qui est très frappant c'est ce que
vous dites au fond de l'état d'esprit de
ce qu'on pourrait appeler la machine de
l'éducation nationale au fond il y a eu
un renversement des valeurs qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui
c'est plus quand il y a un conflit c'est
plus l'élève qui ont dit tiens-toi bien
en haut c'est au professeur qu'on qu'on
va faire des reproches c'est absolument
juste je dirais que la contradiction qui
est au cœur de mon livre c'est le fait
que c'est on a demandé à Samuel Paty de
s'excuser pour une rumeur créée par une
élève qui n'était pas dans la classe
comme si c'était lui qui est comme si
c'était la victime de la rumeur qui
devait en quelque sorte s'excuser de la
rumeur qui le calomnia je rappelle
simplement par la clarté le contenu de
cette rumeur qui est extrêmement grave
qui consistait à dire que Samuel Paty
avait exclu les musulmans les élèves
musulmans de sa classe parce que
musulman donc cette rumeur qui faisait
de Samuel Paty en islamophobe va
évidemment créer une dynamique infernale
et mon livre consiste à décrire
décrypter décortiquer l'attitude de
l'éducation nationale face à ce que les
Anglais appellent un testing c'est à
dire une façon qu'on les islamistes de
tester vraiment une structure pour voir
si elle craque et comment elle peut
craquer alors essayez de essayer de
d'aller plus au fond dans ce que vous
démontrez il y a cette notion terrible
mais qui existe c'est le d'abord pas de
vagues oui bien sûr bien sûr ce qui est
arrivé à Samuel Paty je dirais que c'est
la face tragique visible de l'iceberg
mais cette
transaction qui fait que le professeur
est toujours
la variable d'ajustement lorsqu'il y a
un litige toujours ce que j'appelle moi
le Fotis idéal c'est un long processus
qui vient de très loin donc
effectivement ça s'inscrit dans cette
dans cette longue tradition
malheureusement de l'éducation nationale
et
Samuel Paty évidemment a été la victime
de ce processus là et si on va plus loin
encore vous citer d'ailleurs des textes
officiels de l'éducation nationale qui
disent au fond les professeurs doivent
établir un lien de confiance avec les
élèves c'est assez extraordinaire quand
on y réfléchit hein parce que mais tout
à fait le propos d'un professeur c'est
d'enseigner c'est d'apprendre vous avez
tout à fait raison et je vrai que c'est
pire que ça c'est qu'en fait c'est un
nouveau jeu disciplinaire ou celui qui
juge le bon comportement de du
professeur c'est l'élève donc si vous
voulez et ça c'est incarner très
concrètement ça paraît très abstrait des
comme ça pédagogiquement mais ça c'est
incarné très concrètement par si vous
prenez l'accusation qui a été adressée
par sa hiérarchie qui est qu'est-ce
qu'on lui a reproché au moment même où
il était la victime d'une Kabbale
d'islamiste
orchestrée par un fichier s
Abdelhakim s'effet oui qu'est-ce qu'on
lui reprochait on lui a reproché il faut
reprendre les termes d'avoir froissé ses
élèves donc en quelque sorte c'est
l'élève le ressenti même il faut aller
plus loin même le ressenti religieux de
l'élève qui détermine le bon ou le
mauvais comportement d'un professeur
laïque vous voyez l'aberration
pédagogique que ça représente mais
derrière cette
aération il y a un vrai enjeu politique
évidemment et on va y revenir mais c'est
en effet
cette atmosphère qui explique une
inexplicable au fond c'est dire que on
sait et l'éducation nationale et des et
les islamistes et les terroristes vont
prendre au sérieux le mensonge de cet
élève mais c'est toute c'est toute
l'horreur de la chose je dirais c'est
que le paradoxe si vous voulez du
référent laïcité c'est qu'il confirme la
thèse de l'élève qui n'était pas dans la
classe et qui dit qu'il a offensé tous
ses élèves et il affirme le témoignage
des élèves qui étaient dans la classe et
qui disent mais pas du tout il y a une
très bonne ambiance etc donc ça c'est le
paradoxe qui est au cœur de mon enquête
alors autre chose que vous montrez qui
est assez effarant c'est que en effet il
y a des plaintes de parents d'élèves qui
disent des élèves musulmans ont fait
l'objet d'un traitement raciste mais
pire encore il y a des collègues
qui disent mais on peut pas traiter des
enfants comme ça parce qu'ils ont une
religion une autre religion enfin que la
religion musulmane c'est ça
tout le monde parle à leur personne ne
sait pas sur un mensonge c'est
exactement ça alors il faut pas
généraliser c'est certain collègues
voilà mais c'est vrai que parmi toutes
les accusations
auxquelles Samuel Pathé a dû faire face
celle d'une des plus douloureuses à
certainement été l'accusation de deux
collègues qui sans vérifier le contenu
de la rumeur sont montés sur leur grand
chevaux et on commençait à condamner
moralement le professeur Patty alors
même que la première des choses c'était
de savoir si c'était vrai ou faux et au
fond ça accentué encore le climat de
solitude
construite administrativement de Samuel
Paty et on est dans ce que vous appelez
d'ailleurs le ravage de la suspicion et
de la présomption de culpabilité parce
que c'est ça c'est exactement ça la
rumeur porte sur une accusation
d'islamophobie et
elle a été renforcée
tragiquement par les différents acteurs
et quand je dis différence c'est bien
des acteurs qui ont des rôles différents
c'est à dire il y a l'administration il
y a l'accusatrice c'est-à-dire l'élève
via le rôle des islamistes il y a le
rôle des parents tout ça il faut le
reconstituer mais tout a été dans le
même sens pour accuser un homme innocent
alors la principale lui demande
d'ailleurs de faire des excuses et
d'ailleurs il le fait ce qui est la
preuve que c'est pas un
jusqu'au-boutisme
au contraire c'est pas du tout le
contraire même c'est tout le contraire
c'est quelqu'un qui voulait absolument
bien faire son travail c'est je pense
que le mot qui le caractérise le mieux
je répète toujours cette expression de
Spinoza qui qui que je trouve très belle
probité un signe je pense qu'il a
simplement fait preuve d'une très grande
probabilité et que son geste de
prévenance s'est retourné a été
construit après coup par des islamistes
en
comment dirais-je en geste d'accuse
comment dire stigmatisation en
stigmatisation raciste envers les
musulmans ce qui est évidemment une un
mensonge éonté mais qui a été répandu
sur la toile avec les conséquences que
l'on connaît il a dit à certains sens de
l'humour parce qu'il dit voilà l'année
prochaine je parlerai de la censure
d'Internet en Chine comme ça on n'ira
pas et vous racontez d'ailleurs que
l'année précédente il avait parlé des
caricatures de Jésus et ça n'avait posé
aucun problème
mais vous avez absolument raison de
parler de cette plaisanterie parce que
vous savez les plaisanteries ont
toujours un rôle capital c'est elle qui
désigne véritablement les rapports de
pouvoir lorsqu'on envoie son rapport son
lorsqu'on lui on dépêche sur place un
référent laïcité
sammalpatite est beaucoup moins naïf
qu'on a essayé de le faire croire
comprend très bien la fonction de ce
référent et cette blague qui consiste à
dire ok je parlerai plus des caricatures
de Charlie Hebdo je parlerai l'année
prochaine de la censé en c'est
évidemment une façon de dire je sais
très bien ce que vous êtes en train de
faire vous dites vous citer d'ailleurs
une phrase que vous aviez écrite dans un
autre livre mais qui est très importante
et très intéressant dites tous les
hommes sont égaux mais ceux qui n'ont
pas d'humour sont plus égaux que
d'autres bon c'est toute la culture du
respect que j'ai de quoi on peut rire
c'est quand même important mais c'est un
engination c'est un enjeu fondamental
mais en tout cas je voulais sans sans
ouvrir aller trop loin dans cet enjeu
qui effectivement fondamental je voulais
insister sur cette plaisanterie de
Samuel patati qui montre
sa lucidité en réalité il était à la
fois très lucide sur la Kabbale des
islamistes qu'il nomme nommément c'est
quelqu'un qui nomme les choses donc il
dit les islamistes locaux donc qui la
cabale des islamistes pour perturber son
cours sur la liberté d'expression et
puis il est aussi très lucide sur le
rôle pour le moins ambivalent de son
administration qu'il accuse au moment
même où il aurait besoin d'être défendu
alors continuons sur cette
administration parce que ça c'est
absolument presque incroyable il y a
donc on a parlé des parents d'élèves on
a parlé de quelques collègues mais il y
a pire que ça
se sert de ce faux témoignage
l'inspection d'une inspection qui va te
dire
qui reprend la thèse du mensonge en
disant voilà il a il a rompu ce lien de
confiance avec les avec les élèves là
c'est c'est même très c'est presque une
saloperie j'allais dire ce rapport parce
que il dit oui il s'en est pas perçu
hein
c'est mal conduit c'est ça exactement
vous avez parfaitement compris le livre
et bien vu la boucle que je décris c'est
au fond vous avez donc la situation
quelqu'un qui est pris en charge par des
islamistes et un référent laïcité qui
confirme la thèse de l'élève qui n'est
pas dans la classe donc qu'il aurait
effectivement
froisser ses élèves qui est une thèse
pédagogiquement absurde mais qui va être
c'est ça qui est incroyable qui va être
validé par le rapport de l'Inspection
Générale donc l'inspection générale
reprend la thèse du référent laïcité
donc je dirais presque valider
somnambuliquement sans se rendre compte
de la contradiction pédagogique que ça
représente parce que si effectivement
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure le
comportement d'un professeur dépend de
la sensibilité religieuse de ses élèves
il y a pas d'enseignement laïc possibles
donc
l'inspection générale reprend
somnambuliquement la thèse du référent
laïcité qui en plus repose sur un
témoignage qui est celle de l'élève qui
était pas dans la classe
en tout cas confirme ce faux témoignage
et va être repris somnambuliquement par
l'Éducation nationale puisque
l'éducation nationale va s'appuyer sur
ce rapport donc vous avez une boucle
incroyable aux personnes ne s'aperçoit
un que la thèse initiale est fausse
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'a pas froissé ses
élèves et deux que le fait de lui
reprocher ça est une contradiction
pédagogique donc là on est dans
l'absurdité la plus la plus profonde oui
c'est ça le rapport dit il a du mal à
percevoir son erreur
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que ça serait
une une affirmation qui serait d'un du
plus haut comics si elle n'était pas
tragique dans ses conseils oui ça serait
pas d'ailleurs c'est ça qui est bon que
des terroristes se servent de d'un
mensonge elle était là pour aller
évidement ça c'est on va pas s'entendre
à ce que les amis c'est la vérité mais
vous citez beaucoup Kafka d'ailleurs
hein
mais c'est totalement kafkaï que
l'administration de l'éducation
nationale se servent de ces mêmes propos
qui sont faux qui sont en mensonge oui
vous savez il y a une phrase
merveilleuse de Kafka qui résumerait
même toute son oeuvre c'est la procédure
se transforme en verdict et la procédure
qui a mise en accusation petit à petit
graduellement c'est cette graduation que
j'ai vraiment décrit parce que ça ça
commence par des par des
presque anonyme bon bah vous voulez bien
vous excusez etc oui oui ben voilà bon
et puis on se rend compte que cette
première cette première appel va avoir
des conséquences très graves parce que
on va profiter de cet appel pour dire
vous avez reconnu votre erreur donc
maintenant vous allez la reconnaître
vraiment et donc vous avez un processus
comme ça qui est quelqu'un en tout cas
ensuite évidemment le déchaînement des
réseaux sociaux
avec avec oui abdelkim
lui un fichier un fichier s euh connu
etc qui va devant le le collège filmé en
disant il ne nous respecte pas ça c'est
le troisième accusateur celui qui le
traite de voyou il dit ce voyou doit
être renvoyé de l'éducation nationale et
le père et le Brahim c'est Brahim c'est
voilà de la jeune élève menteuse donc
qui a d'ailleurs reconnu après coup sur
6 mois plus tard
qui lui est là aussi
dit qu'il va livrer lui alors je crois
que c'est 17 octobre le nom de Samuel
Paty et le lieu il a eu évidemment un
rôle capital je si vous voulez tout vous
savez l'islamisme fonctionne par le
renversement accusatoire donc j'ai lu
très attentivement les les postes
Facebook de MC et surtout les
commentaires c'était extrêmement
instructif et donc son tout toute sa
version commence par incroyable mais
vrai
et donc il va raconter une thèse fausse
évidemment on a exclu des élèves
musulmans parce que musulmans etc donc
il va répondre ça mais je veux toujours
attirer l'attention sur le fait que des
parents d'élèves de confession musulmane
ont refusé de rejoindre cette cabale et
il faut saluer leur courage et leur
lucidité voilà ça c'est très important
parce qu'ils ne sont pas absolument
tomber dans le piège identitaire que
leur tandem les islamistes
alors en effet oui un certain nombre de
parents qui sont entre guillemets bien
conduit oui mais absolument on sait pas
entre guillemets qui se sont
remarquablement conduits
on attend dans mes c'est vrai que s'il y
avait pas eu ce drame terrible qu'il a
décapitation c'est-à-dire la peine de
mort quoi telle qu'on la pratique
pratiquait ça serait il est accusé
d'avoir diffusé des des images
pornographiques de ces élèves il est
obligé d'aller s'en expliquer au
commissariat et c'est d'ailleurs là
c'est le 13 octobre là où c'est une
scène capitale qui bizarrement
n'apparaît pas dans le rapport où Samuel
Paty dit très clairement je n'ai commis
aucune infraction dans l'exercice de mes
fonctions c'est vous dire que lorsque le
référent laïcité c'est absolument de lui
faire reconnaître une erreur donc une
chose fausse à savoir qu'il aurait
offensé ses élèves
voilà ça n'a pas marché Samuel Paty
reste tout à fait propre par rapport
rapport à ça démarche et c'est très
important de rappeler ces mots à lui
parce que dans le rapport tout est
toujours rapporté aussi indirect si
l'index c'est un signe très confortable
on sait quel est son état d'esprit dans
ces jours-là on sait que par exemple il
prend très très mal les accusations de
ses collègues et qu'il évoque un
huissier parce que l'accusation de
de racisme apporté par deux collègues
avant même de vérifier le fait que la
rumeur enfin la consistance de la rumeur
et pour lui quelque chose de très grave
et qui ne le vivrait pas de façon très
grave quand on est absolument pas
raciste comme c'était le cas évidemment
de Samuel Paty
et tout ça fait qu'on va arriver à ce 16
octobre avec ce détail qui est terrible
aussi c'est des élèves qui vont désigner
en Europe la victime c'est le
monsieur qui a Jean une chemise rouge
c'est ça quelle ironie pour une petite
somme en plus 350
350 euros
j'ai du mal encore à qualifier cet acte
en réalité des élèves effectivement ont
attendu pour voir comment on allait le
châtier pour reprendre le terme des
islamistes et donc il y a une sorte de
curiosité pour le moins malsaine qui
s'est mis en place
certains élèves ont attendu deux heures
que Samuel pâtit pour pouvoir le
désigner deux heures c'est très très
long
donc il faut quand même une moi je ne
sais pas comment qualifier cet acte mais
en tout cas je l'ai décris sans le voilà
on the Rohff là qui est donc l'assassin
on sait à peu près d'où il vient qu'il
est on sait on sait peu de choses de lui
on sait simplement cette chose très
ironique pour un État français qui est
accusé d'être raciste qu'il a été
accueilli que sa famille a été accueilli
pour lui éviter les français
pour lui éviter les persécutions alors
qu'il est de confession musulmane donc
ça c'est un très très ironique que
devrait méditer tous ceux qui accusent
l'État français de racisme alors c'est
comment il s'est procuré les couteaux à
Évreux vous la racontez il y a
aujourd'hui je crois 16 personnes qui
sont inculpées dans cette affaire le
père de la de la de la jeune élève
paraît-il ce
poste dans une posture de victime on va
dire bah je savais pas que je savais pas
de mentir etc enfin bon ils ont quand
même
dans les commentaires vous savez dans
les commentaires des de ces postes
Facebook il y a quand même quelqu'un qui
a écrit cette histoire c'est trop gros
c'est pas possible j'y crois pas il
avait tout le temps de se poser les
vraies questions lorsqu'ils ont lui a
proposé d'échanger avec Samuel Paty il a
refusé c'était une campagne d'islamiste
ces gens-là savaient très bien ce qu'il
faisait
un propos qui est très important dans
votre lit que vous écrivez vous dites
Samuel Paty n'est pas mort pour la
liberté d'expression il est mort de
l'antiracisme islamiste oui je voudrais
préciser ce point c'est c'est un point
important c'est important pour ce n'est
pas un martyr il a pas voulu mourir pour
la liberté d'expression et je crois
qu'il faut se tenir à distance de tous
ces discours martiaux auquel on a eu
droit leur de la cérémonie officielle je
crois qu'il faut il faut il faut fuir
l'émotionnel pour rester dans l'analyse
et ou alors le symbolique pur qui n'a
pas beaucoup d'importance
l'analyse nous apporte à démontrer que
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'en réalité
quel a été la posture victimaire des
islamistes c'est de dire
on nous a traité vous savez il y a une
phrase incroyable quand c'est fruit dit
si on avait été Juifs on nous a reçu
tout de suite on nous aura pas fait
attendre donc
voilà donc vous avez le victimisme vous
avez l'antisémitisme très présent et
puis alors cette logique toujours qui
consiste à dire et puis bien sûr la
confession j'allais presque oublié
l'essentiel qui est la vidéo de l'élève
qui a menti et qui se présente vraiment
comme la victime on ne nous traite pas
nous musulmans comme les autres en fait
dit-elle donc là vous avez bien une
posture victimaire qui va comment
dirais-je précipiter l'engrenage
idéologiquement c'est pas c'est pas un
fait divers c'est un c'est un engrenage
qui s'inscrit dans un dans un
environnement idé c'est très particulier
où le victimisme un rôle très important
vous dire vous êtes tout un chapitre sur
sur l'islamisme
par l'Office idée notamment
oui
Indigènes de la République et vous citez
un
chercheur qui s'appelle Philippe
d'iribarn
qui explique au fond le fond du combat
des islamistes il y a deux choix pour
les musulmans soit ils rejoignent des
infidèles soit
ils vont dans ce combat peut-être pour
identité
non non mais bien sûr je crois qu'il
faut pas se cacher que il y a une
volonté de déstabiliser mais vous savez
pas simplement la France pas simplement
la laïcité française moi un point sur
lequel j'insiste toujours c'est que le
même chantage la même pression le même
testing le même tentative d'intimidation
s'est déroulée en Angleterre quelques
mois après donc un professeur a fait un
cours sur le blasphème et à
contextualiser comme Samuel Paty le la
caricature de Charlie Hebdo je rappelle
que cette caricature faisait partie du
programme donc il était pas encore voilà
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs l'éducation
nationale ne lui reproche pas du tout
d'avoir montré la caricature il faudrait
pas se tromper de cible et lui reproche
d'avoir froissé les élèves bon
à mon sens c'est pire mais enfin si on
comprend bien pourquoi c'est pire mais
la même chose s'est produite en
Angleterre avec le même tentative
d'intimidation et
le professeur a dû être exfiltré
alors si vous voulez si c'était un
problème lié à la laïcité française bah
ça ne se passerait qu'en France or c'est
un problème qui se déroule quasiment
dans les mêmes termes partout en Europe
si c'était la laïcité parce que il s'est
passé aussi quelque chose d'aussi
absurde c'est que du fait que Samuel
Paty ait été décapité on a mis la
laïcité française en procès donc ça
aussi ça participe de l'absurdité de la
chose et donc mon parallèle avec
l'Angleterre c'est que si c'était la
laïcité en France ça ne se passerait
qu'en France tout simplement or ça se
passe partout en Angleterre l'Angleterre
qui a des principes complètement opposés
à la France du point de vue de la
laïcité qui a une religion d'État par
ailleurs vous citer la formule de
djihadisme d'ATM qui est présent dans
l'enseignement dans l'université
notamment
ça aussi oui vous pensez que c'est très
présent mais c'est extrêmement important
ce concept est extrêmement important
pour comprendre la responsabilité de ce
que faisait et brahmc et ses free oui
c'est à dire vous laissez courir une
rumeur
sans vous engager directement vous
salissez le nom d'un homme et puis vous
attendez que quelqu'un passe à l'action
on peut pas utiliser ce terme on peut
pas utiliser l'accusation des
slamophobie innocemment ça n'est pas
possible on sait que cet accusation tu
on en a la preuve
peut-être une dernière question qu'on
nous appelle poser parce que je vous en
prie mais est-ce que est-ce que la mort
de Samuel Paty a servi à quelque chose
et bien écoutez là encore on revient en
fait à la première question je dirais
que il y a deux possibilités il y a une
possibilité une tentation très forte du
point de vue de l'éducation nationale de
tourner la page pour oublier les
circonstances exactes et la
responsabilité directe de
l'administration dans la non protection
de du professeur Patty et puis il y a
aussi peut-être je l'espère la
possibilité de méditer ce qui s'est
passé pour que un autre professeur ne
passe pas par le même cauchemar le même
enfer mais ça ça suppose qu'on décrive
honnêtement le plus précisément possible
ce qui est ce qui s'est véritablement
déroulé et ce que j'ai essayé de faire
dans mon livre
[Musique]